we're here to talk about our most
anticipated xbox one games of next year
some of these throughout the show today
for those watching live we're going to
be kind of crisscrossing between
platforms so some of these won't be Xbox
one exclusives they might be you know
ps4 pc but we're kind of like giving
them up and then these breakouts will
not go up until like the 22nd I think
when we actually start you know doing
our most anticipated stuff on the site
anyway Xbox one I have crack no
scalebound first scale bone was that
demo at e3 was kind of funny for all of
us just between the jargon that okay so
main character name is Drew so it's from
platinum games you know Bayonetta metal
gear rising revengeance fame they're
also working on near autumn otta which
we're getting into later in the ps4
segment yeah this dude drew is working
with a dragon Thuban or Toobin i don't
know how to pronounce it completely but
we watched the demo at e3 and you just
fighting this massive boss kind of like
a devil may cry / bayonetta taking sorry
boss it's alex i'm just like a colossus
very much the opposite of glass
Guardians farstone yeah yeah i mean
between you know the war cries they have
and the apparently you can just snap
into a first-person go to control the
dragon every once a while but obviously
look at like looking this gameplay here
you see this giant massive crab boss
rising out of the water that you end up
fighting you know bow and arrow
apparently there will be like firearms
later that degrade over time it's an RPG
action RPG it's billed as so you know be
ranking up your character throughout
picking up new weapons I'm sure it looks
fun i would say especially if they can
kind of nail that dragon / human combat
almost like titanfall maybe the balance
between different to different scales
scale mount um yeah what do you guys
think of this game Jake it did you play
yeah we have any has played any of this
I'll just laid it I think it looks cool
i remember maybe was this he threw the
last III they should a demo and it was
running like garbage like it was head
poor frame rate it didn't look that good
but looking at this this looks this
looks pretty cool yeah i i'm curious
like how long i actually be able to play
this though like I feel like it might
get monotonous
after a while but I mean the scale is
definitely there thing going for it
obviously PlatinumGames I mean they know
it seems a little bit monotonous at
first just that kind of basic balance of
range and close off attacks but then you
keep playing these games like Bayonetta
or metal gear rising and they just keep
getting more nuanced as you go and they
know how to pace their games so or
legend of korra which was pretty bad I a
legend they range so much like I don't
know what to expect with platinum games
that it's gonna be great or it's just
gonna be like can I yeah you're totally
right i mean again the most recent thing
i play by them was near autumn otta
preview again we're talking about that
later on the show the live show but it
it definitely looks like something I
want to play just watching this you know
you get up close and this is just boss
fights obvious I'm sure not everyone is
big but I don't know what that was I
have a hard time understanding what
exactly you're doing in this game though
it is it an open world I've seen clips
of like you and the dragon like just out
in the field and stuff and then as these
boss battles what is like the three word
classification of this game so it's I
mean they're saying action RPG okay so I
don't know that it's gonna be open world
you know like near autumn Otto will be
this might be kind of more a linear
devil may cry thing with like these I
feel like in box yeah I feel like we've
seen like sandbox areas for this like
yeah cuz Bayonetta was entirely linear
yeah remember they're supposed to be
co-opted to write or multiplayer so yeah
wasn't it for players taking on that
Boston III yeah yeah i don't know like
it looks promising I'd like to see you
know seen an action obviously uh not
sure exactly when that releases I can
check that out but I've been working on
it for a while too definitely yeah so
it's because they announced it a few
years ago right it was like everyone was
it's like gamescom or something like
that like definitely years ago yeah
there's no exact release date still 2017
for xbox one microsoft windows so we'll
hear more about that if not like before
e3 then at e3 or something um crackdown
3 which i think everybody kind of got
excited about when they saw the
Microsoft Azure power destruction I just
essentially you can level the whole city
if we're running i think p proud would
be good to talk to about this he
understands like the technical
components of it but yeah what seems
like Roy the city
it was using a cloud server type type of
yet process where like a bill each
building and in a certain area would be
devoted to a server and operated on the
cloud so like if you were blowing up one
building it would they basically i think
i saw up to like they having a debug and
they're showing like up to like 12
different servers when like you were
leveling like you know like a whole
block that game looks insane they were
shiny like footage of like God basically
just like shooting a wall and was able
to create a hole to snipe out of the
destructible environment of that whole
city sounds insane ambitious but yeah
fish I could pull it off definitely fun
I'd the first crackdown I played a lot
that was one of my early xbox 360 games
i was like that and call of duty to if i
recall correctly i did not like the
second one all that much it felt really
repetitive and what you were asked to do
but yeah just once you start getting all
those agility orbs and just like a
behind-the-scenes documentary watching
but once you get all those jilla orbs
you'd leap like up 20 story buildings
with one jump you just become so
overpowered in the best way and
combining that with these destructible
environments that they're promising
would sounds pretty awesome well like if
you see on a building would you just
level the building and then pick it up
off the ground yeah it's like kind of
the opposite of what i would want to
destroy everything um and tack on the
fact that it was i believe it was co-op
that they showed footage of like um I
forgot where I saw it but yeah all of
them are Berto ops so yeah sure this one
I need to make sense this one be
co-opted as well it'd be weird that's
one of its tenants I would would be
surprised if they kind of just did
without at this time yeah crackdown was
like one of the first sort of open world
games that had co-op I thought that was
so cool yeah kick a doodoo like I don't
know LAN connection just yeah be
screwing around the city with a friend
yeah I took a while to wrap your head
around the fact that you could do that
with games back in like two thousand
seven or whatever it was but yeah this
looks promising to say the least it's
just I don't know no other games have
kind of like try to do this yeah with
the cloud so I'm losing what happens it
was just this domino effect yeah
obviously this is pre alpha but I'm
really curious to see what they end up
doing with like NPCs are creating people
in this city right cuz sure leveling it
be a whole lot of fun but these people
Johnny is a daily business or is it just
empty you know I mean I that won't be
that obviously but I'm just curious to
see like the actual city yeah my
cooperation what was the deal the first
two games there were NPCs all over the
city right there weren't you or like not
many right well no not a lot the second
one there was like a zombie outbreak
that was the whole thing you're doing
zombieness and then figuring out how to
destroy those um I don't know what the
actual like civilian population was like
I imagine the first game wasn't too
populated if it was like a early xbox
360 game mm-hmm but I'm looking forward
to that though yeah another one we have
listed here which is not just like Xbox
one exclusive prey which I am really
really excited for mainly because I love
Dishonored 2 which I just finished and
it's also Arkane Studios is following in
the vein of you know looking glass games
Deus Ex the system shock that kind of
first-person choice and consequence you
know like storage driven adventure
Dishonored 2 is you know we keep talking
about around the office it's a great
game that we really enjoyed I myself
really like I loved first dishonored
prey is the other side of arcane studio
so Harvey Smith being creative director
of dishonor to raf colantonio over in
France will be heading up pray or is
heading up pray I can't wait for this I
mean it's cool like the story itself the
premise school so essentially based on
the fact that JFK survived the
assassination on a 11 22 63 and then
like continued pouring funds into space
research so up to the fact to the point
where we were actually like pretty
progressive in space and that aliens
took notice and you are Morgan you on a
space station which again this is all
just System Shock like on a space
station the original prey on 360 which I
didn't play much I think I will kind of
consider a cult classic right I I blade
it yeah imma being sick because you'd
like run up like upside day and like
yeah I was a launch title wasn't it it
was close to launch i think it was like
a couple months after yeah so yeah but i
mean this one you can transform into
coffee mugs you can actually get through
space she looks wack e it's it seems
like dishonor to but obviously sci-fi
and just on acid also dark
like the the whatever alien villain it
is in this game looks creepy as all hell
like something had a dream half a night
Muriel I can't wait for this I mean it
seems like combining kind of the
isolation of alien and you know that
choice driven plot gameplay of dishonor
those games i mentioned the looking
glass vein of games that people have
been so affected by even like origin
systems back in the day i can't wait for
this this office has an actual release
date yet i think prey is uh yeah i mean
a 2017 right now but I it just looks
like it's going all out like batshit
crazy with things you could do and then
obviously you're getting like these
sci-fi weapons that are becoming kind of
iconic I I never I didn't play that
original one the the story to like it
seems more interesting than dishonor to
like this honors world i think is is one
of the best things about that game but
the story was kind of weak and this at
least judging by like the trailer
they've showed they've shown the premise
seems super-interesting like I feel like
they could do something really cool with
this story yeah definitely again this is
not a xbox one exclusive per se it's on
ps4 and microsoft windows as well but
figured we would slide it into this
segment because we got a lot of ps4 and
xbox one games talking about but anyway
I don't know about you guys you missed
anything else I mean we're talking about
Mass Effect Andromeda on the pc section
ukulele do you guys play were you big
fans of banjo kazooie and touhy yeah I
definitely played banjo kazooie um I
played that what they call it the toy
box or something toy bomb um i don't
know i mean granted that was just you
know essentially the ability just kind
of try all the movement and get a
general very general idea of maybe Leo
what that game would feel like I I don't
know i piec know people it's it's it's a
crowdfunding uh yeah i mean that's
that's all good i think people are
really excited for it i'm definitely
like happy people are i just don't see
much value personally out of it I mean
it just looks exactly like banjo kazooie
yeah I'm excited for it but yeah like
you said it's I'm excited because it's
kind of reviving the 3d platformer which
is you know all but almost disappeared
in Reese
years except for like knack or that has
a sequel so maybe it is coming back who
knows but I played about an hour of this
actually when I was over in London
platonic showed me a section of the game
they just kind of let me wander around
and collect I figured that it's
obviously like jiggy's jigsaw pieces and
banjo kazooie until I was collecting
like pages in this it felt really good
some camera issues which is like 3d
platformers you know are made or broken
by their their cameras like the Last
Guardian but I'm looking forward to it
I'm it's this again this isn't a xbox
one exclusive it's a really see on all
platforms but yeah yeah they totally was
gonna say that that was the one like
major gripe or I keeled at what point
for like any kind of third person game
do you do you allow you know a camera to
like auto turn or all the auto follow
because I felt like you were really it
was really stiff and that toy box at
least I played like you felt like you
were fighting the camera and it was
getting lodged in like walls and stuff
um hopefully they address that and then
one I do want to mention as well I
didn't really have a ton of fun with the
first battlefront not the first battle
front but like the 2015 a reboot the EA
battlefront they are slated for 2017
release or at least like rumored or
whatever battlefront 2 will be releasing
um I don't know what to expect from it I
think we've heard some things about this
I don't know what we're supposed to talk
about yet so I'm not even gonna risk
anything well yeah I mean I know what I
want what do you want I want campaign
yeah duh yeah like AG lacked a conquest
type of idea yes that because that was
that was the best looking to ya oh my
god both those base tues spaceballs be
great just being able to switch sides
yeah I have a completely different like
we hone to everything I mean rogue one
releases in two days you have force
awakens out already we know like it just
seems like Star Wars is in full on push
it seems weird not to take advantage of
of all these news stories excuse me that
I right now coming out in each of these
movies a campaign would make sense and
and that is the biggest i would say
maybe an overall like gripe with like
well lobby Star Wars games lately and
you could even vouch for like some of
the latest movies is
this is a franchise that I think I only
one called franchise a universe that so
many people adore however what's getting
tired some is seeing so much of that
original trilogy like come on let's take
some liberties let's push things things
forward yeah uh you know battlefront
lacks in that and even some of the DLC
that came afterwards just like the last
one is like an x-wing it you're in space
and what do you get to fly just an
x-wing yeah come on like this is like be
way there are so many things as far as
on Arsenal t you could have and create
that I just you just not seeing a lot of
creativity in and out you know and that
you know you could also vouch that
that's reason why Lucasfilm maybe that's
the real block right like you have to
like go through them and it's very tight
and I'm as it should be you know it's
canon you got it like up here to the
rules but imagine EA and dice though
could probably get that get access to
that pretty easily though yeah well like
and just to keep vamping on that the
star wars x-wing VR mission that came
out with battlefront those guys who made
the game were able to basically design
an x-wing cockpit and then show it to
Lucasfilm they said that's awesome this
is now canon via like I interview those
guys I won the last preview event it was
freaking awesome like there are people
who are I feel like kind of taking that
route but I'm just sick and tired of
like an 80 80 what like ha thank you
hawtt can we get off that planet and
just maybe the idea of like an 80 80 and
Walker salt like just like an unbalanced
I don't know premise that is just tired
it's just been done like I just want
battlefront to be something new well
what about so the original battlefront 2
they started incorporating the prequel
trilogy that's fine by me add yeah and
that is just like all military stuff and
that's fine as long as you don't get too
much into the story the prequels that's
where you kind of enter rocky waters but
do you think that you just play DLC
recently can you talk about it yet yeah
absolutely it's not right now no one
there's rug one so do you think they'll
take more advantage that battlefront 2
because it from
I'm reading early reviews from all like
major publications saying Road one's
pretty good right and there's apparently
like the third act well I won't even say
it but like apparently there's a lot of
cool like choreographed battles and like
special effects and the battles
themselves are actually much larger
scale than you might think based on
trailers and rogue one that we've seen
so far yeah wonderful take advantage of
that would battlefront two yeah I think
a lot of it is just time like you know
you look at valve run I think even
frankly this DLC wasn't all that
outstanding to me and you just get the
real obvious indication that these are
games that were that were stripped of a
single player campaign in order to make
force awakens deadline right like once I
think hopefully you know like you have
like respawn working on some Star Wars
title like once we can get i'd say like
another year in maybe battlefront like
there hopefully they're doing you know a
lot spend a lot more time on it yeah
that we can start start seeing some
really cool star wars games I just like
now it's like it's back Star Wars is
back let's like mass-produced this
franchise like a Marvel case and games
are like falling behind it and that's
the problem is like you know you game
doesn't like come out in a year sure
like this isn't really platform centric
but obviously like the star wars game
that Amy Hennig is working on I can't
wait for that I don't know if it's gonna
be 2017 or not that used to be 1313
should working on with visceral Studios
so we'll see what happens with that
maybe we'll hear more about that next
year but of course that's going to be
very narrative Lee driven knowing a me
headaches experience with you know like
the Uncharted franchise as an example
that's exciting yeah so obviously we
wish we had more time but those are a
handful of our favorite ex or our most
anticipated xbox one games coming on
2017 so if we missed any or we have any
major ones that you want to talk about
leave your thoughts in the comments
below
you